[Musique]
des îles démocratiques et libres
apportées de mains de la Chine
communiste autoritaire la ville de
Siemens se trouve à moins de 5 km des
îles Kidman
[Musique]
ici les souvenirs des bombardements
chinois sont profondément ancrés
[Musique]
un peu comme c'est piquets anti
débarquement qui personne les plages
depuis le tournant des années 60
un vieux char d'assaut rouillé témoigne
de la guerre froide et de cette période
d'extrême tension
[Musique]
avec 10 ans lorsque les bombes ont
commencé à s'abattre sur les îles Kidman
en 1958 le privant de l'insouciance
d'une jeunesse normale
forcée de grandir trop rapidement il a
dû interrompre ses études afin d'aider
sa famille il s'offre enfin un peu de
paix quelques heures chaque jour réservé
à son passe-temps préféré la recherche
de roche spéciale qu'il pourra peindre
lorsque les bombardements ont commencé
le 23 août 1958 il se rappelle de la
peur des abris de fortune fait debout et
d'avoir fui dans les montagnes loin de
son village
entre 1958 et la fin des années 70 la
Chine a tiré plus d'un million de buts
sur les îles Kidman plusieurs musées
témoignent de la guerre et de la
mobilisation de la population lors de
ses attaques
des dizaines de milliers de bus chinois
se retrouvent maintenant ici dans
l'atelier de maestro who
né en pleine guerre froide il a grandi
sous les bombardements chinois
aujourd'hui il transforme ses obus en
ustensiles et autres accessoires de luxe
pour la cuisine il peut forger 60
couteaux à partir d'un seul obus
c'est une façon pour lui de tourner la
page sur cette guerre du passé chacun
des obus transformés en ustensiles est
un rappel que la paix est possible et
qu'elle doit être préservée
une paix de plus en plus fragile dans le
détroit de Taïwan comme en ont témoigné
les exercices militaires de la Chine et
de Taïwan l'été dernier
des manœuvres militaires qui soulignent
la précarité de la situation dans
laquelle les îles Kidman si proches de
la Chine se trouve même si la majorité
des résidents disent ignorer les
tensions dont les médias font état
nous sommes pris dans un étau entre la
Chine et Taïwan affirment ce politicien
indépendant tout comme Taïwan est coincé
entre la Chine et les États-Unis nous
pouvons être la ligne de front d'une
guerre mais peut-être aussi le canal de
communication entre toutes les parties
les
îles Kidman ont quelque chose d'atypique
un monde unique aux caractéristiques
taïwanaises mais avec une proximité
géographique et économique avec la Chine
les liens
identitaires avec le continent sont
encore plus étroits pour beaucoup de
résidents avant la pandémie des bateaux
effectués la navette chaque jour entre
siamen en Chine et les îles Kidman
plusieurs commerces vivaient d'ailleurs
grâce à la visite des touristes chinois
malgré les douloureux souvenirs des
bombardements de nombreux résidents des
îles Kidman entretiennent des liens avec
la Chine et en conserve une opinion
favorable
ton Johnson va même plus loin malgré les
horreurs des bombardements par la Chine
il ne se considère aucunement taïwanais
mise en scènes sont originaires de la
Chine et je vis sur un territoire
gouverné par Taïwan affirmative avant
d'ajouter qu'il préférait être dirigé
par si gin ping plutôt que par les
forces indépendantistes taïwanaise
cette femme rappelle que chinois et
taiwanais partagent la même langue et
les mêmes racines même si elle souhaite
que le statut quo soit maintenu elle
croit que la réunification est
inévitable
résidences sont contre le communisme
mais pas contre la Chine elle-même ni
contre sa culture ou son économie
précise-t-il c'est une importante
distinction
one ligne a longtemps partagé cette
opinion avant d'aller étudier à Taïwan
aujourd'hui même si son conjoint est bon
nombre de ses amis sont chinois elle se
déclarent fièrement taïwanaise elle
reconnaisse pendant que les résidents de
Taïwan en général en connaissent peu sur
la réalité particulière des îles kindman
contrairement à la majorité des
résidents de Kidman one ligne ne
s'empêchera pas de parler de politique
c'est l'occasion de communiquer avec des
gens de tous les horizons et de faire
changer les choses
la communication pour prévenir une
guerre beaucoup de résidents des îles
Kidman dont maestrow se rattachent à cet
espoir
n'oublions pas que c'est toujours le
monde ordinaire comme vous et moi qui
souffrons dans ces guerres dans style
les tensions dans le détroit de Taïwan
l'affecte pas il a connu le vrai stress
de la guerre
il ne croit pas que la Chine veuille
vraiment attaquer Taïwan mais si elle le
faisait joue-t-il et l'emporterait
facilement ne serait-ce qu'en coupant
l'électricité en provenance du continent
[Musique]
si les souvenirs des bombardements
chinois sont encore solidement ancrés
dans la mémoire des habitants de ces
îles démocratiques et libres c'est sans
doute pour rappeler que l'histoire a
parfois la mauvaise habitude de se
répéter
[Musique]